tributes pouring in for legendary
Broadway composer Jerry Herman Herman
died Thursday at the age of 88 he wrote
such classic shows as ma'am named Maine
Thank You Thank You Dana
and of course Hello Dolly Jim Axelrod
has a look at Jerry Herman's award
waiting career and his tuneful optimism
when it came to musicals you brought the
cake walked back into style Jerry Herman
was simply and quite unapologetically an
old school lover of hope and sunshine
Jerry creates songs that I like him Tom
C buoyant and optimistic
Herman created upbeat Tony award-winning
Broadway shows like Hello Dolly name and
lacasa fall which won a Tony in 1984 and
more complex and cerebral shows were
trending there's been a rumor around for
a couple of years that the simple
hummable show tune was no longer welcome
on Broadway
well it's alive and well at the palace
[Applause]
Firmin simple hummable show tunes on him
a shelf full of Tony's and Grammys as
well as recognition as a Kennedy Center
honoree Jerry Herman gone Ted 88
produced old-fashioned musicals and
old-fashioned toe-tapping joy
[Music]
consider this is context for Jerry
Herman's optimism he was diagnosed with
HIV in 1985 the early days of the AIDS
crisis and then lived another thirty
four years Jim Axelrod CBS News
Washington
amazing to think about that yeah that is
incredible I'm a Broadway baby all of
his musicals I admit it I know a lot of
those words thank you for asking
me a whole rant about the movie Rosalind
Russell Dana and her whole makeup and
hair team and our crew was like
[Laughter]
you